djebbour qui est contre la science et le
vite
la séance est levée la séance est levée
[Musique]
christophe bouillon député de la 5e
circonscription de seine maritime
jusqu'au 17 juin 2020 est aujourd'hui
maire de barentin dans ma
circonscription
c'est le choix de la proximité c'est le
choix de l'action c'est le choix aussi
de revenir un mandat que j'ai connu et
qui m'a beaucoup plu et qui m'a
passionné
mr plutôt que député le non cumul exige
des choix christophe bouillon a fait le
sien il tourne le dos à 13 ans de vie
parlementaire dans cette circonscription
de seine maritime
il doit maintenant fermé sa permanence
sans regrets mais avec une pointe tout
de même de nostalgie voilà c'était mon
bureau les vider et ça c'est là la
plaque était sur le mur que j'ai
décroché ça fait drôle donc décroché la
plage quand même passé la dernière
affiche voilà que je fasse le tri il est
tous là ont échappé à la poubelle
quelques badges délivrés plus étonnant
des dossards de course
je cours en fait et donc je faisais lady
killer beaucoup de kilomètres donc coin
de tous les 10 kilomètres qui avait
souvent mais au cas chaque fois je
revenais avec le maillot souvenir
alors ça c'était pour le téléthon voilà
avec mon mec
une participante donc je vraiment j'en
ai fait beaucoup
ça c'est enfin ouais c'est des bons
souvenirs parce que pour ça je les garde
d'ailleurs parce que parce que voilà ça
rappelle des moments que j'ai passés et
puis et puis c'est vrai que ça
surprenait ambiguïté de
pas simplement être à la remise des prix
lui aussi de courir c'était plutôt sympa
et dans un coin une collection que seul
peut avoir un élu de terrain d'une chose
qui est formidable c'est les
inaugurations ségala une truelle
souvent quand vous avez procédé à une
première pierre eh bien vous faites un
exercice très commun à vos classiques
formidable collection de truelle en tout
genre
alors parfois vous avez des indications
pour dire ce que c'est voilà donc ça
doit y en a à la pelle et cruel le reste
des affaires a fini dans ces sacs
poubelles adieu la circo adieu
l'hémicycle christophe bouillon trace
désormais sa route vers la mairie
le choix n'a rien d'un coup de tête
depuis trois ans il s'est senti gagné
par un étrange syndrome le blues du
député
quand on est à l'assemblée on décide pas
tout seul et on le sait c'est plutôt
l'exécutif qui décide d'aller souvent
c'est lui qui donne le la
c'est lui qui décide l'ordre du jour
c'est parfois un peu frustrant quand
vous êtes maire vous assumez pleinement
vos décisions parce que vous en êtes là
la source
le blues des députés c'est vrai que moi
je le ressens et il est lié à sa veillée
à 7
cette impuissance cette incapacité
parfois à vouloir aller plus loin il y
aurait-il une crise existentielle chez
les députés
ils sont 20 à déserter ainsi le palais
bourbon pour les hôtels de ville
heureusement le code électoral a pensé à
tous ces députés seront remplacés par
leurs suppléants a priori de simple
formalité
le remplaçant de christophe bouillon le
voici seul maire ça va bastien coriton
les maires de la commune deux rives en
scène quatre mille trois cents habitants
a su renverser passé de maire d'une
petite commune à député de la nation
voilà une occasion qui à 38 ans ne se
refuse pas et pourtant bon et toi il
n'ira pas j'ai reçu le mail de
confirmation de l'assemblée nationale
noc ma démission était bien enregistrée
et sa décision est sans appel
de toute façon j'étais face à un choix
et le choix il a été de ceux des
rebelles où je me sens plus utile ou
est-ce que je pense que mes levier sont
les plus importants pour changer la vie
pour changer les choses dans ce choix là
est bien le prisme s'est décalé sur la
commune une décision presque
inimaginable il ya quelques années
décidément le mandat de député n'est
plus le graal en politique non une
génération à son âge il se trouve qu'on
a quand je suis devenu député j'ai l'âge
cas bastien aujourd'hui c'est à dire
donc à son âge je vous réponds oui je
suis devenu député parce que c'était une
belle chance en plus on est tous les
deux de milieu
simple populaire dans les familles du
coin donc être député c'est aussi une
forme de reconnaissance une sorte de
degré d'élévation aussi dans le parcours
donc franchement franchement à 18 à 38
ans quand tu devenu député c'était un
grand moment pour moi
un député et son suppléant qui font faux
bond en même temps le cas se présente
dans six circonscriptions
une situation inédite qui va entraîner
autant deux législatives partielles à la
rentrée dans l'hémicycle c'est l'heure
des adieux la parole à monsieur
christophe bouillon merci monsieur le
président comme le dirait eddy mitchell
c'est ma dernière séance c'est à dire ma
dernière question
et pour cette dernière intervention
christophe bouillon a choisi de parler
de cette famille modeste dont il est
issu ma mère m'avait dit la politique ce
n'est pas pour nous et depuis ces
longues d'année j'ai tout fait pour ne
pas lui donner raison
et pour faire en sorte que le fils de
marin et de femmes de ménage que je suis
est sa place ici et si j'ai beaucoup
donné parfois au détriment de mes
enfants oscar et hermann c'est pour
faire en sorte que ou ceux de leur
génération ne se dit jamais que la
politique ce n'est pas pour eux je suis
de ceux qui pensent que notre assemblée
est capable de nous élever elle l'a fait
lorsque nous avons tous ensemble entonné
la marseillaise au moment des attentats
et pour certains d'entre nous elle a
fait aussi lorsqu'elle a voté le mariage
pour tous ou la pma pour tous je suis
persuadé qu'elle le fera encore vive la
république merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
bouillon je ne dirais pas ça en temps
normal mais non de non vous avez bien
fait de ne pas écouter votre mère et
permettez moi de penser que même si vous
lui avaient désobéi
elle doit être sacrément fier de vous
les départs comme celui de christophe
bouillon touche presque tous les groupes
politiques
chez les républicains pas moins de dix
députés ont ainsi quitté le navire
je trouve que le parlement va
s'appauvrir c'est vraiment dommage parce
que en fait on perd des gens qui sont
actifs travailleurs qui étaient sur des
problématiques et on gagne aussi des
gens qui ne souhaitait pas venir
moi je vois a eu et suppléants qui est
mais moi je voulais pas devenir député
j'étais très content d'être mère merci
au revoir camarades
à bientôt
[Musique]
et les camarades justement les députés
socialistes
comment prend-il ce départ comme
favorite
ça va mais toi bonne écoute nouvelle vie
voilà monsieur et regrette déjà de ne
plus nous voir à terme oui
ça oui franchement franchement ce que je
trouve mon petit op moi j'ai franchement
attendre un peu voilà c'est un dilemme
qu'il a dû trancher
[Musique]
vous avez fait la promesse qu'à partir
du moment où il y avait le cumul aurait
plus de pouvoirs plus de levier d'action
d'initiative mais surtout des moyens de
contrôle la vérité c'est que tout ça
n'est pas au rendez-vous et encore moins
là aujourd'hui un sentiment
d'impuissance considérable c'est presque
la question je voulais être posée est-ce
que la dégradation que je considère
qu'il ya une dégradation vitesse grand v
des deux de nos marges de manoeuvre et
de nos moyens d'agir est ce que cette
cette dégradation des conditions
d'exercice du monde a débuté à compter
dans sa décision
oui ça a pesé oui ça c'est certainement
parce que un moment ou un autre
s'épanouissant de faire ce qu'on fait
mais à condition d'un moment à l'autre
on fasse un peu bouger les lignes
c'est possible un sentiment d'inutilité
largement partagé pour christophe
bouillon un épisode a sans doute pesé
en décembre dernier le député
spécialiste des questions
d'environnement défendre une proposition
de loi pour la reconnaissance du crime
déco side avec l'idée de créer un nouvel
outil législatif pour sanctionner les
peaux mineurs soyons clairs nous sommes
encore trop tendre avec ceux qui
détruisent en conscience par appât du
gain et par calcul notre environnement
est ce que la france va être oui ou non
au rendez vous si oui qu elles prennent
date et 4 volts la loi que nous vous
proposons aujourd'hui proposition
retoqué comme la plupart des textes de
l'opposition ses distances ne conduiront
donc a donné un avis défavorable à cette
proposition de loi est pourtant six mois
plus tard la proposition revient par la
grande porte de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat c'est l'une des mesures
phares retenue par le président de la
république des citoyens tirés au sort
ont donc eu plus d'influencé qu'un
député la reconnaissance christophe bull
on la trouve auprès de la patronne des
députés ps
j'ai dédicacé 7
ce rapport que tu as écrit à mon cher
christophe sur l'éco sinon je sens que
je vais me faire des mots dire ce que je
pense comme d'habitude je pense que
c'est la plus belle proposition de loi 2
du groupe
donc là je sais que j'avais avoir
quelques ennuis mais c'est pas grave
j'assume et donc avec cette citation
mitterrand il ya toujours un amiens pour
ceux qui pensent l'avenir voilà
et cette proposition - elle pense
l'avenir et elle est ultra ambitieuse et
je trouve qu'elle est à ton image
c'est-à-dire de toujours voilà voir un
cran n'avance donc un petit souvenir de
17 je veux pas d'angoissé à l'arrière le
biz mais le coeur y est énorme et roy
aura tout fait plaisir
[Musique]
l'heure est aux échanges d'amabilités
pourtant valérie rabault pourrait en
vouloir à christophe bouillon la
partielle qui s'annonce dans la
circonscription peut faire perdre un
siège au parti socialiste associés mais
je n'espère que j'espère que ça c'est là
la clé de cette réponse
ce sont les électeurs qui l'aide et les
électrices qui la détiennent qui peut
selon lui quand même pour faire le
maximum pour gravir mais j'ai pas besoin
de compter sur vie parce que lui aussi
il envie de je le sais et puis j'ai pas
besoin lui dire voyez c'est vous qui le
dites c'est pas moi je vais mouiller
dans cette campagne je vais y mettre
aussi beaucoup de moi même si par
malheur
cette circonscription se détourner du
chemin qui a été le sien depuis des
années oui forcément j'aurais une pointe
une pointe d'amertume déjà largement des
plumes et aux dernières législatives
le groupe socialiste devra affronter
deux législatives partielles à la
rentrée mais qu'est ce que vous voulez
me faire dire je vais je vous dis que je
suis triste oui je vous dis que oui le
groupe ps continuera à mener les combats
je vous dis je vous dis que oui
l'assemblée nationale n'a pas les
grandes heures passées mais ça c'est pas
la responsabilité des groupes
d'opposition
c'est la responsabilité du groupe
majoritaire souhaite à christophe sait
que il va s'épanouir
l'environnement sera au coeur des débats
de la prochaine session parlementaire
mais c'est désormais en spectateur que
christophe bouillon les suivre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]